[Musica]
lo spettacolo sta per cominciare e io
sono dietro le quinte mi viene la
tentazione di affacciarmi una cosa che
in teatro e vietatissima non si può fare
però non c'è nessuno in giro e io mi
affaccio e li vedo sono tutti lì il
pubblico seduti brulicanti e c'è un
elettricità nell'aria che mi investe mi
viene addosso e io in quel momento
capisco che quello ciò che voglio fare è
la mia cosa ho otto anni e siamo allo
spettacolo delle scuole elementari in
realtà però lo facciamo al teatro
comunale di pietrasanta che il mio paese
e ci sono 500 posti e fra i genitori
parenti amici e tutto pieno quindi c'è
tanta gente un po come qui oggi
allora vado dalla mia mamma e gli dico
io voglio imparare a recitare solo che
siamo alla fine degli anni settanta in
versilia non è che ci siano tutti questi
non sono ancora non esistono ancora i
talent tutte quelle robe televisive
quindi corsi di recitazione non ce ne
sono molti ne troviamo uno sparuto mi
iscrivo e cominciò a studiare c'è
un'insegnante di roma un ex attrice
molto brava che ci fa fare delle cose
anche impegnative dante alighieri
bertold brecht jacopone da todi m riesce
tutto facile
i miei compagni di studio di teatro sono
tutti più grandi io sono la bimba loro
hanno intorno ai vent'anni e ogni tanto
si bloccano
c'è qualcosa che non viene magari un
sentimento che non riescono a far uscire
io ci soffro riguardo è perché a me
viene facile io lo vorrei fare io
poi a un certo punto succede che dopo un
po che studiamo un paio di anni
cominciamo ad allestire uno spettacolo e
quindi bisogna andare in scena qualcosa
comincia a prendere una brutta piega
io ho paura cioè più che più che paura o
proprio degli attacchi di panico
solo che all'epoca questa espressione
non esisteva o almeno intorno a me
nessuno sapeva di che si tratta
c'era il fatto che prima di ogni
spettacolo io comincio a star male gli
organi si contraevano io stavo malissimo
ero terrorizzata mi sembrava di andare a
farmi ammazzare mi buttavo in terra
piangeva urlavo e andava avanti così per
giorni non era una cosa dell'ultima
mezz'ora per cui anche in casa dopo un
po a vedermi soffrire mi dissero lascia
stare insomma non è non è il caso
e quindi lasciai nessuno pensò e
tantomeno lo pensare io che il problema
non era il teatro c'era un problema
psicologico dietro però fece un altro
percorso di vita anche bello perché poi
ho fatto studi umanistici mi sono
laureata in lettere e ho iniziato
piano piano a diventare un artista
visiva facendo installazioni un percorso
non facile ma bello facendo mostre un
pochino a milano poi all'estero
a un certo punto faccio un progetto a
new york per il consolato generale
d'italia un'installazione che dura un
anno quindi anche una soddisfazione però
c'è qualcosa che non torna yo sotto
sotto sono frustrata cioè come una
sofferenza intanto vado in analisi per
risolvere antichi problemi ci vado
quattro volte perché faccio quattro
diversi percorsi di analisi nel corso
del tempo l'ultimo dei quali dura dieci
anni e lì qualche nodo effettivamente lo
sciogliamo vorrà dire che sono una
persona risolta e assolutamente
eccessivo però pochino di equilibrio
comincio a trovarlo e risale questa
frustrazione
ricordo che al mio terapeuta gli disse
con la mia arte col col mio lavoro mi
sembra come di avere una voce grossa
così è tutto quello che riesco a tirar
fuori e b cioè la mia sensazione è che
rispetto al segnale che vorrei e mettere
a quello che ho da dare è come se
dovesse passare attraverso un imbuto mi
esce solo un pil e quindi comincio a
interrogarmi su questa frustrazione che
intanto sale sale passa il tempo io ho
già compiuto 40 anni che faccio
ricomincia a balenare in testa sta cosa
teatro recitare ma nel frattempo me lo
sono dimenticato perché avendolo dovuto
sotterrare non è
non è più una cosa che io ricordo di
aver abbandonato però dai e dai decido
faccio un tentativo mi iscrivo a un
corso di teatro ne cerca uno che mi
sembra quello più buono proprio ganz e
lo trova a firenze ora io avevo in
versilia per cui per tre anni vado a
firenze tutte le settimane o anche
indietro con la mia macchina col caldo e
col freddo con la pioggia e col vento e
frequente questo corso e poi siccome per
far questo mi comporta tempo energia
anche soldi che non ho per cui mi
organizzo mi faccio il panino mangio in
macchina nel parcheggio prima di entrare
al corso parto con il thermos del tè
però ci vado non sono mai esempio in tre
anni avrò fatto un assenza ci sono
sempre mi piace tantissimo perché io ho
rimesso un piede nella mia cosa poi vi
ferma a dormire a firenze perché il
corso finisce tardi quindi mi appoggio a
una cugina che sta sui colli per cui
guido nella notte vado lì insomma un
certo punto
l'insegnante di teatro ci propone di
scrivere dei monologhi scrive un
monologo
e poi non mi fermo più continuo a
scrivere monologhi è un certo punto
questo i monologhi meli registro col
cellulare così lo appoggio in camera una
piletta di libri mi registro e limando
alle mie amiche
a un certo punto ne scrivono che appunto
all'errore di si chiama l'errore di base
parla di quegli errori che facciamo noi
donne spesso nel rapporto con l'uomo
cioè lambiccarsi straordinariamente il
cervello per cercare di correggere o lui
o noi per far funzionare un assaggio una
relazione che semplicemente non funziona
perché a volte è anche così questo
monologo lo mando alle mie righe dopo
averlo registrato in una maniera anche
abbastanza casereccia cioè non aspetta
neanche di averlo imparato a memoria
quindi lo leggo mi registro mentre leggo
sbaglio due volte e lo mando così
neanche sono entusiaste e cominciano a
mandarcelo fra di loro
l'antico panico ha lasciato qualche
traccia
[Applauso]
mando il monologo così un po fatto
marino alle mie amiche se lo passano e
le donne cominciano a passarselo con
whatsapp e qualcuna sconosciuta
l'opposta su facebook tutto a mia
insaputa come disse qualcuno dopo di che
questo video nel giro di ventiquattr'ore
diventa virale in 24 ore fa un milione
di visualizzazioni poi milioni così
anche cosa regista tomalino insomma una
performance che non era un granché non
ha neanche recitato benissimo che
succede io comincio a vere donne che mi
ringraziano mestrino le e mail followers
come si dice che mi seguono
per cui pubblico altri monologhi ne
continua a scrivere né continua a
pubblicare costruiscono spettacolo fatto
di monologhi scritti da me e lo porto in
giro e lo recita in teatro dopo un paio
di mesi mi chiama una casa editrice una
delle più grosse d'italia e mi chiede di
scrivere un libro bene tra scrivere
questo libro poi collaboro con una
piattaforma per fare monologhi di
divulgazione culturale quindi parlo di
libri di film bellissimo in pratica nel
momento in cui ho messo il piede nella
mia cosa
la strada è spianata ecco il concetto è
molto semplice
secondo me è quello che fare la tua cosa
è già il successo
poi il mondo può rispondere subito o
dopo di più o di meno ma tu stai già nel
successo sei già bolden brilliant perché
stai facendo
la tua cosa
avevo previsto una domanda sulla paura
che però è già stata evidente dice la
paura di allora paura c'è ancora c'è
sempre cioè ogni volta ogni volta che
vado in scena c'è anche oggi qui forse
si vede anche insomma però però a un
certo punto ho capito che dietro quella
paura c'era un desiderio e il desiderio
era più forte e quindi ha prevalso
vi lascio con una frase di amedeo
modigliani che è il tuo vero dovere e
salvare i tuoi sogni
[Musica]
e voi state salvando i vostri sogni
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]